pour en parler nous recevons l'invité de
ce journal le général Jean-Paul
Palomeros merci d'être avec nous ancien
chef d'état-major de l'armée de l'air
ancien commandant de l'OTAN pour
commencer on revient sur ce qu'il s'est
passé hier l'Ukraine dit avoir abattu 54
des 69 missiles tirés si ces chiffres
est exact que l'on serait la
signification est-ce que cela voudrait
dire que l'Ukraine a désormais les
moyens de répondre par les airs aux
attaques
oui alors il y a une amélioration je
dirais constante de la défense entière
aérienne
ukrainienne grâce d'abord à l'apport des
armements qui sont les vrais pas par
l'ouest la France a livré par exemple
des missiles crottel et donc de nombreux
pays ont livré au fur et à mesure des
missiles et des systèmes anti-missiles
performants on parle des patriotes aussi
qui seront sans doute bientôt déployés
et puis les Ukrainiens eux-mêmes se sont
mieux organisés ils ont amélioré leur
couverture cela dit bon quelle que soit
le ratio une défense antérienne c'est
jamais parfait et malheureusement on
voit les effets des missiles qui passent
il y en a il y a quand même des
destructions on a encore le système
électrique qui a été sévèrement touché
hier donc ce n'est pas parfait mais il
faut qu'il continue à se défendre comme
ça pour protéger au maximum leur
population parlons des cibles justement
général par le micros quand la Russie
frappe les infrastructures énergétiques
quel est l'intérêt quelle serait la
stratégie sur le plan militaire
alors c'est une stratégie de terreur que
qu'a choisi la lumière Poutine terrorisé
le peuple et essayer de porter atteinte
à
des moyens vitaux si vous voulez sans
énergie évidemment un peu plus vivre et
c'est vrai aussi pour l'industrie et
donc c'est vrai quelque part pour la
défense donc les Ukrainiens doivent
faire preuve de beaucoup d'imagination
beaucoup de souplesse beaucoup de
résilience pour arriver malgré tout à
poursuivre cette guerre en dépit de
cette pression permanente et ça monsieur
Poutine l'a bien compris et c'est pour
ça qu'il continue cette guerre se
poursuit qu'en est-il du front ou
peut-être des fronts est-ce qu'on est
déjà dans par exemple le front gelé qui
évoquait la spécialiste il y a quelques
semaines
non j'ai jamais tout à fait adhérer à
cette théorie enfin je l'ai peut-être
sur des positions en ce moment mais il
est toujours actif en tout cas il est
chaud
il est on le voit la bataille pour dans
le Nord alors pour marcmouth est
incessante c'est devenu d'ailleurs un
symbole pratiquement de la résistance
ukrainienne d'un côté de la volonté à
des Russes de d'obtenir au moins un
succès futile
symbolique et le nord c'est très
important évidemment il y a toutes les
lignes d'approvisionnement donc premier
élément stratégique sonore ou les
Ukrainiens aimeraient bien pouvoir
avancer mais ça ça demande aussi de
mettre en oeuvre des réserves c'est un
peu pareil dans le sud ou là les
Ukrainiens aimerait bien avancer sur
médito Paul mon sens mais il faut qu'il
prenne une décision très difficile
d'engagement d'un certain nombre de
réserves humaines
pour se faire donc je crois pas que les
Français je l'ai il y a une certaine
réflexion stratégique en tout cas au
niveau des Ukrainiens d'un autre côté
les Russes eux essayent de monter en
puissance leur réserve à peu près le
tiers peut-être le quart des réservistes
qui ont été engagés à ce stade s'ils
arrivent à engager dans de bonnes
conditions et services ça peut changer
les choses si justement le fait que ces
choses puissent ou même doivent changer
puisque le statu crois en l'état est
absolument insupportable pour pour
beaucoup
jusqu'où par exemple ce conflit peut-il
aller évidemment on a posé la question
dès le début nous sommes aujourd'hui
quasiment un an un an après le début des
hostilités vous avez dit il y a quelques
jours chez nos confrères de Radio
Classique que l'Occident mène un peu une
guerre par intérim jusqu'au l'Occident
peut-il aller dans ce conflit face à des
Russes qui ne semblent pas vouloir
lâcher non plus
est quand même extrêmement important il
s'agit d'un pays j'ai un pays qui était
libre souverain garantit par la Charte
des Nations Unies si
par malheur l'Occident mais c'est la
garde ça serait une très grosse défaite
et donc c'est vraiment pas
le choix qui a été fait on le sent bien
aujourd'hui je suis allé à Washington le
ministre de la Défense français est allé
à Kiev pour réaffirmer ce soutien donc
je crois que le soutien l'Occident il
est assuré et même si c'est difficile
évidemment puisque les outils de défense
sont sollicités et ils ne sont pas
inépuisables
voilà donc pour l'instant on voit pas
vraiment d'issue les conditions de
négociations ne sont pas remplies il
faut résister résister encore soutenir
les Ukrainiens dans leurs efforts et
puis voilà essayer de trouver avec eux
quels sont les meilleurs voix les
meilleurs capacités militaires qui
peuvent leur permettre de faire la
différence merci beaucoup général
Jean-Paul par le mérost d'avoir été avec
nous sur France 24 ancien chef
d'état-major de l'armée de l'air ancien
commandant de l'OTAN merci beaucoup